[Music]
good morning everybody
I'm Nick Martin I'm head of Google's
cloud business for retail in the UK well
done for making it here 9:00 a.m. on the
final day of our Google next conference
we recognize that we had some stiff
competition from the party last night
and also Vicky know that's taking place
at the moment so so a big well done and
thank you for choosing this session to
spend some time with us this morning I'd
like to start the session with an
insight into retailers most important
asset the shopper shoppers today are
curious demanding and and impatient
shoppers have more touch points with
your business than ever before they
visit your website they use your app
they come to your physical store call to
your customer service line join your
loyalty program what's your YouTube
videos stop by your Facebook page
subscribe to your email lists and more
they also see your ads search social
video TV radio print and out-of-home so
these interactions produce a wealth of
information about your customers and
what they want from your business good
news for business well not necessarily
if that information is not used
effectively in fact according to a joint
study Google conducted with Greenberg at
least 62% of people expect brands to use
their purchase history to provide them
with personalized experiences yet only
42% think most brands currently do so
why is that is it an impossible task to
deliver relevant personalized
experiences at every touchpoint what are
the reasons that may prevent prevent
this typically an organized state an
organization's data is spread across
many places ad campaigns CRM systems
customer service logs website app
analytics loyalty programs and many many
more
so this this means it can be very very
difficult to get a single view of each
customer so it's no surprise that almost
60% of marketers according to forrester
say that it remains difficult to give
stakeholders in different business
functions across access to data and the
insights that they need and without it
how can they create truly personalized
experiences but to deliver that kind of
experience that your customer now
expects organizations need to take a
very different approach the key thing is
you need to have all of your data not
just some of your data in one place
structured and unstructured all
different types and when it's in one
place then you're in a position to
unlock the most valuable insights it
provides cloud solutions enable you to
break down data silos and organize your
data such that you can better analyze
and activate it to gain better insights
and drive better and more predictive
outcomes we speak with many
organizations who are actively working
to incorporate artificial intelligence
and machine learning into their data
analytics strategy yet the vast majority
of those organizations are at the very
earliest stage of AI initiative
according to the Gartner survey a CIO
survey last year it's reckoned that only
4% of CIOs
currently have AI underway within the
organization yet this is set to change
rapidly over the next two to three years
in fact it's reckon by 2020 more than 85
percent of organizations will have AI
programs under pilot or in an
operational mode so why is that well to
adopt AI customers face many many
challenges technology the scale needed
to handle AI is massive from an
operational perspective you
to have the right expertise in place the
right people but very few organizations
have those people their ass curse breed
and tooling which to date has been very
narrow in terms of the options it
provides and requiring much
specialization so realistically ai has
only been in the hands of very few
people very few organizations in the
last few decades and it's those who have
had access to deep computational
resources training and specialized
expertise in machine learning
organizations that are technology or
intered so you need to embrace new
approaches and adopt technologies like
artificial intelligence but doing that
is a huge operational challenge this is
where Google cloud comes in Google cloud
is Google's public cloud computing
business and brings a variety of
products and services to provide you
with AI at scale so I choose Google for
AI well we provide that massive scale
the same computing power that powers
Google search Gmail Maps Android and
many others which have over a billion
users today we provide high performance
a global infrastructure as a service
leveraging Google's technology in
servers processors and private fiber
network and the quality of technology
with a range of innovations Google has
developed for data management analytics
and artificial intelligence and bringing
together customization for a cloud AI
solution with an approach we take to do
advanced solution labs where we will
develop innovation with you our
professional services capability and the
extensive range of business partners
that Google has is how we bring this to
you to provide that AI capability in
your organization and improve your
productivity
we provide a spectrum of AI and machine
learning tools and you would have heard
some of these being further announced
during this conference and this is
enabling you to leverage your
organization's capabilities and skill
sets and also your big asset in client
on one end we have pre trained
out-of-the-box models for companies that
don't really have that expertise
in-house and you can use pre trained
models like vision API video API video
analysis natural language API or
translation API to deliver certain
experiences to your customer on the
other end of the scale you have Google's
market leading open source machine
learning engine tensorflow which lets
your data scientists build their own
models to solve customer challenges
within your business and in the middle
we offer managed services like cloud ml
that brings the best of both worlds
together so you can customize models for
specific use but use our managed
services to test train and scale your
models in the cloud now enough for me
what you're really here for is to hear a
real customer who's been doing this so
to bring it all to life I'm absolutely
delighted to introduce and welcome onto
the stage John T angel who is head of
Accardo technology and a good friend of
Google Cloud Shanthi thank you hello
so John t to kick things off um can you
explain the the Accardo business model
and-and-and a little bit about Accardo
for us sure so should I take that
Elise's thank you cool so firstly thank
you for having me here it's always great
to be in San Fran the weather's not
unbelievable you know I came in from
London where it's about 36 degrees and
heat wave so however it is nice to be
here and nice to be with everyone thank
you also for coming this morning I know
after the party last night probably
you know not easy to wake up and come to
the 9 a.m. session so and thanks Nick
for that introduction so to answer your
question what is a card oh and you know
what businesses are in accord oh so
quickly by show of hands who has heard
of a card or or interact with a cada ok
good so that means my colleagues who
have been speaking also at some other
sessions have done a good job because
there's some hands up who's used a
corner before ok so very few hands ok so
basically a cada at a high level is is
really a fusion of two businesses on the
one side we have a retail business which
if you've lived in the UK or you've
actually used the service or being into
London and seen some of the vans you all
know that we run an online grocery
supermarket where we take orders in and
through a series of supply chain
activities we then deliver in order to
people's houses and actually we go
further than that we go into the kitchen
and deliver it into the kitchen so it's
a great end-to-end service but you can
have your groceries delivered in a 1
hour time slot that's our retail side of
the business and depending that we have
a technology business which actually has
only really comes lights over the last
few years in the public eye the
technology business focuses on building
the platform that powers that retail
business so things that are important
are all of the learnings that are
happening in the retail business all of
the specific customer requirements and
then this retail real time feedback loop
that we get from our retail customers
interacting with the record or brand so
what you have here is this unique fusion
of two businesses with an amazing
feedback loop that's real-time so on the
one side we learn it from customers
because we have an online supermarket
and on the other side we build in
technology to
you support that service so then who is
a card oh so Accardo is the world's
largest dedicated online grocery
retailer we have over 600,000 active
shoppers we have a range of over 50,000
SKUs across our four automatable users
and we pick around a quarter of a
million orders per week so for an online
only business with no stores that's
quite big just to give you an
understanding of the number of orders
this is a picture which was taken
actually in San Francisco on an ad for
sony bravia they they released a whole
lot of bouncing balls into the street
and actually they're at least 250,000
balls so you know just to give you a
perspective on the kind of number of
orders we do in in a week through our
automated facilities so then taking the
lens and looking through that second
business which is our technology
business the question is what is the
record oh smart platform so this is our
modular and scalable software and
hardware platform designed to put the
world's largest retailers online so we
currently have some partners which you
would have seen in the press releases
are the last year also who have engaged
in this platform and what the platform
aids to do is to deliver a full
end-to-end service for your retail
business so there are three key
activities over here which we focus on
within our end-to-end platform the first
activity is that of shopping so we
create an interface where customers can
come to a website and engage with the
site and shop and add favorites etc etc
and build a basket
once that's complete we then have to
fulfill that order so we have to pick it
and we have our automated facilities and
we also have an in-store picking system
and then once that order is picked and
4-fold we then need to deliver it to the
customer so the third part is delivery
and that's where we you know load up our
vans and using proprietary routing
systems and algorithms we deliver the
groceries to our users either in their
homes or via click and Collect
type portals so an image which which
from a product perspective is a lot
easier to to kind of get your head
around what the platform is would be to
try to divide it into these triangles
where as I mentioned you have the
shopping experience in the top half of
the triangles which is responsible for
the e-commerce activities you then have
our fulfilment trying and effectively or
module which is responsible for
fulfilling those orders and then you
have our delivery module which is
responsible for sending them to clients
and they are all held together with a
core which is responsible for things
like the basket pricing engines all the
specific order management systems etc
etc etc so the platform is is really
modular and scalable but also what this
slide is highlighting is I've listed
their current capabilities are around
you know the things that you
traditionally find in one of these
end-to-end supply chain systems I've
also highlighted future opportunity
examples so the platform's been built in
a way where we can innovate and really
stay on the bleeding edge so for example
IOT robotics or autonomous vehicles
those are all areas we're extremely
interested in and want to enable our
platform to easily engage in
so jaunty can you you mentioned
technology platform can you share
further insights into those platforms
the department and some of the machine
learning innovations that you've
implemented at Accardo to support your
customers yes I can
so in order to answer that question I
would first like to just give you quite
a high-level overview of what the
technology division is a Takada so as I
said we're the tail of these two
businesses the retail and the technology
and what we've we've established is is
it's more than just a division actually
it's almost like a company on its own a
business on its own we have a cada
technology and that's responsible for
building the software that powers a
quarter so we have over a thousand
people working in a corner technology
and more than half of those people are
computer scientists engineers data
specialists and machine learning
specialists so we've invested in people
who have these skills and can build up
the side of our business we also have
European offices where we have
developers in Poland we have two offices
they're actually in Krakov in Ross Worth
and we have an office in Barcelona and
then we also have an office in Sofia in
Bulgaria so we are you know these
officers are first technology officers
both in the platform and you know the
bulk of our development does also happen
in in hetfield in the UK behind a kada
technology there are really three core
principles that that enable us to build
the seamless experience and platform for
our customers that is intuitive
efficient and convenient so what I mean
by intuitive is we make sure that our
web shop experience or our shopping
experience
is very easy to use so anything we build
has to be easy to use it has to be
immediately accessible by our customers
efficient so because we need to do
things fast and a lot of things at scale
like picking orders packing them
delivering them sorting them all kinds
of these operational processes along the
whole end-to-end we need to be efficient
so we effectively need to be efficient
at scale and I've got a video actually
where I'll show you one of our latest
warehouses and how we are building
robots to help us be more automated and
efficient and then convenient well I
have a picture here of one of our
delivery drivers and what this really
means is we need to build software and
applications that are not just great and
fast and out there in the market and you
know quickly in the hands of our
customers and innovative they need to be
convenient easy to use easy to
understand about our employees so in
that delivery driver gets to the door
the first thing that they thinking of is
to offer a great experience to the user
and not to be hung up on the technology
so the technology needs to work for them
to allow them to do their job and that's
one of our principles is we need to
empower our people to be able to easily
use the technology now to achieve those
principles you have to invest in a lot
of back-end skills a lot of capabilities
and what Accardo has done over the years
actually since the start is has invested
in these departments we have a lot of
people who are working on automation and
robotics we have specialists in machine
learning mobile app development routing
systems data science cloud vision
systems simulation I mean if you walk
one of our warehouses you'll see all
these things interacting with each other
and and giving you an insane that and
inside that you know this is a
technology business that you in the
heart of just to talk to to next point
you know for us we we we need to invest
heavily in skills like machine learning
and basically how to use cloud
technologies which prompts us to to
collaborate further with companies like
Google because that investment is
crucial to us taking the next step which
is keeping innovative keeping on the
bleeding edge offering those new systems
building those intelligent personalized
experiences and that's where we want to
be so as a business we've we've
incorporated this in our culture and you
know that's that's how we moving forward
so I've got a video here just just to
show you one of the areas of the
platform which which i think is
extremely impressive
it's basically once an order is ready to
be delivered we have our routing system
that takes over to understand where
orders need to be dropped off and in
what order and the particular vans that
will take them there so you can see this
here is a simulation based on real data
actually and it's just been sped up
across on the entire day what you can
see is every little pin drop is actually
a completed order so as an order gets
delivered you can see that it lights up
like a little drop we probably in the
simulation around midday or 1:00 p.m.
where London gets a bit nuclear so you
can see the activity over there and then
other big patches of activity around our
automated performance centres you can
actually see Dourdan where we have a big
center there and over we have another
one so you know in order to do this we
have to invest
in algorithms that you know can
basically give us the most efficient
routing around our geography to deliver
those orders and you can go to that link
over there to find out more about our
specific routing systems the second
video that I want to show you is of our
latest technology in our warehouses
whoops go back I think I need to click
that so this is end of performance
center and Andover is southwest of
London and as you can see here this is a
view from the top of a grid or hive
structure which is a highly dense
storage system and what you're doing is
you're looking over the grid and imagine
looking at the size of a football pitch
where literally you have over a thousand
robots moving on top of this grid doing
different activities so some of the
activities that the robots do is when
products are brought into the hive from
suppliers
there's robot activity which basically
unpacks and places them in the grid
other activities are bringing products
to areas of the grid where we have a
picking aisle so we actually within the
grid have a picking tunnel and we have
people who are placing products into
different baskets in different
assortments and another function of the
bots which is actually what I think is
the most intelligent is at the end of
every shift the bots run a specific
algorithm
set of algorithms that allow them to do
housekeeping which is they prepare the
grid for the next set of orders so
effectively what happens is we can make
sure that the grid is always stocked
with the orders in the right places to
efficiently for fall the next set of
deliveries so I hope you can get an idea
of the size and you know those those are
charging stations at the back basically
which the bots go off to pretty
impressive I've actually had the
pleasure of visiting that DC and I would
have to say if you ever get the
opportunity to go and visit it's the
most impressive setup and a lot of fun
so John T can you take us how are we
doing can he take us onto how machine
learning is directly providing your
customers with a better buying
experience and service yes so so just
first to introduce you know what is a
benefit for our customers I would like
to share you know the three core areas
that we look every day to improve on is
number one we need to make sure that
deliveries are on time it's more
important to get a delivery on time than
anything because that's the expectation
of the customer the second is great
shelf-life so we need to make sure that
all our products have a great shelf life
so that they are in the life of before
they expire and actually a Carter has a
life promised in that and then almost no
substitutions
so that means when you place an order
you want those products that you ordered
you don't want to see a whole list of
other products which kind of we just
threw in there so you want the products
you ordered so our supply chain systems
need to be efficient and accurate to
ensure that the right stock is in the
right way house if I go on to the
benefits to retailers well if we aren't
focusing on building the technology then
that takes a lot of the risk of them and
they can effectively focus on running
their business so that gives us an
opportunity to develop more intelligent
systems for the retailer to benefit from
so for example one of the benefits is
low waste and and that's because in our
customer journey we have different
mechanisms of offering products
throughout the journey that ensure that
maybe those products that were going to
be wasted can be re offered within the
customer journey there's another one
called know your customer which I'll
talk about a little bit later which is
around customization where we do use
machine learning to get a better
understanding of their the needs of our
customer based on previous orders so
that we can deliver a more personalized
experience and then you know there's a
couple of other ones over here which
which add to the overall benefit that a
retailer gets from using our platform so
more specifically to to answer your
question the two areas that I'll briefly
highlight where we've used machine
learning to positively impact our
customer experience in our platform has
been in fraud detection and in
customization so I have a little quote
up here which which shares kind of the
motivation of of why we we wanted to use
machine learning for fraud detection and
it was really all about how can we have
speed and adaptability so we know that
if we were humans looking at fraudulent
activity and trying to make assessments
and predictions what would happen is
that the fraudsters would effectively
change the way that they operate in a
way where we would need to be really
really quick to keep up with them so
what we felt is that this is a perfect
use case for machine learning where we
could just let a machine do that and if
we had enough data in the background to
to power that
the machines would become more
intelligent and would understand you
know how to spot fraudulent behavior I
actually my colleagues spoke a bit more
about this in in another session I think
it was yesterday and there's a video
which which explains more technically
what we're doing there but you know at a
high level the datasets that we use in
are things like past orders previous
cases of fraud past deliveries the cost
of baskets ordered items so you know
that if someone is effectively every
morning at 9:00 a.m. by in X amounts of
I don't know alcohol and they are just
you know being placed in these random
kind of delivery spots you can assume
that's you know fraudulent activity but
the powerful thing is taking all these
data sets together you get new trends
and you get new ideas and you can
actually for the first time stay ahead
of the fraudulent activity with fraud
what's interesting is in our customer
journey actually we we do our fraud
detection at the front end of that
customer journey so effectively when you
enter the site to start shopping we are
already doing the fraud checks and and
starting to assess fraudulent activity
and that's because you know we want to
make sure that anything that happens
after that is not fraudulent some of the
tools that we use are we really try to
use the whole stack of of google cloud
so we use the ml engine bigquery cloud
storage and tensorflow
and you know this is a really really big
project right now within within our
business this is another diagram which
just gives that whole data flow
so the the last section is customization
so if again you look at the the
end-to-end customer journey where you
start an order you know you start doing
your shopping and preparing your order
and then you go through to complete in
your order to check out what we found is
that the real way to impact a customer
is to show them things at the end of
that customer journey which will allow
them to have an amazing experience and
you can now do that using machine
learning because the way we've employed
it is we get to know more about our
customer based on their previous orders
and favorites so that we can offer them
things in the last pages of checkouts
which they wouldn't necessarily think
they could be offered for example the
page that we offer is called have you
ran out of and that is a system where if
I always you know every third week buy
dishwashing tablets and I get to their
third week where I'm now completed my
basket and the system has recognized and
I don't have the dishwashing tablets it
will prompt me and it'll say well how do
you ran out of this you know do you
expect to to buy these
that's an amazing service because if I
can add that to my basket without having
to see it not been in my order and you
know the frustration that comes after
that I'd be an extremely happy customer
so the benefit to the customer is that
they get to not be inconvenienced by
products that they leave out of their
shop because they've forgotten it so
they do in their shop for a purpose and
sometimes it's those products that they
leave out for the retailer this is
massively beneficial because the
retailer gets to build a bigger basket
so it gets to make sure that the
customer is both happy
and the basket is is increasing in size
with those essential items and there
again we use you know a large extent of
the Google cloud to build this machine
learning engine so that's really you
know what I wanted to cover today and I
hope I've answered your questions I
believe so
thank you John T that's been well I'm
sure you'll agree with me a fantastic
insight into the Accardo business model
and also use of technology and machine
learning so a huge thank you measure
thank you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]